who are the top 10 greatest warriors in
a song of ice and fire which characters
are best at fighting in their prime
years with their usual weapons and armor
this ranking is based on the books in
the time period of the main series and
robert's rebellion no dragons or warging
or magic allowed giants and white
walkers don't count
the number 10 best warrior is victarion
greyjoy the iron captain
victarion wasn't in the tv show but he's
an uncle of theon and asher and
victarion is renowned among the ironborn
as a fearsome warrior he's a big man
strong as a bull and about as smart as a
bull but that just makes him braver
victarion wears heavy plate armor even
in sea battles which is dangerous
because he could drown if he falls
overboard but victarion is afraid of
nothing he lives to fight he was put on
this earth to deal death with his axe in
book four victarion single-handedly
slaughters a bunch of men in battle then
he kills a knight called talbot sarri
sarri is fast but victarion's fast too
catching ceres sword in his armored hand
victarion's hand gets wounded and
infected so a red priest called macquaro
heals victarion's hand with magic and
now vick's arm is burned black and
smoking and is stronger than ever
victarion lifts a man in the air and
kills him with just this bare hand
so with his new super strong barbecue
fist victarion may be even more
dangerous than before
but we never see victarion fight any
really skilled opponents talbot sarri is
not a particularly renowned knight and
victarion's bravery does border on
stupidity so while victarion is powerful
there are better fighters
number nine is loris tyrell the knight
of flowers loris is just 16 years old in
book one but he's already famous as a
great knight he's graceful and quick and
very skilled at fighting author george
martin said that lloris is one of the
best swordsmen in westeros and he's
extremely good at jousting in
tournaments but oberyn martell questions
whether loris is any good in actual
battle so what fights has loris won we
see loris lose a fight with brienne in a
melee loris kills two knights who were
on his side out of mad grief lloris
apparently fought magnificently at the
battle of the blackwater but not as
magnificently as his brother garland in
book five loris leads a savage assault
on dragonstone and kills a bunch of men
but lloris gets badly wounded and doused
in boiling oil and is expected to die
so loris is a talented fighter but he
doesn't have many impressive fates of
battle and his arrogant recklessness is
a weakness that may have just got him
killed jaime thinks lloris has the
potential to be great but so far that
potential is unfulfilled
number eight is brienne the maid of
tarth brienne is freakishly big and
strong she's well over six feet tall
bigger and stronger than jaime she's a
skilled fighter and moves shockingly
fast in battle and she's even more
dangerous with the valyrian steel sword
oathkeeper
in book 2 brienne wins a melee at
renly's camp she's the last standing of
116 nights and she personally defeats
loris tyrell one of the best warriors
alive though loris claims that she won
with a trick by tackling him brienne
often uses her size and strength to
overwhelm opponents her fighting style
is similar to that of her ancestor
duncan the tall
after renly dies brienne fights off a
bunch of his men with speed and skill
and in book three brienne fights jaime
lannister one of the best swordsmen in
westeros it's a long hard fight but try
as he might jaime can't kill her and
eventually brienne beats the kingslayer
though she realizes that jaime is
weakened from months of imprisonment and
his hands are chained together so
brienne thinks that jaime would have won
if he was at his full strength in book
four brienne fights some of the brave
companions or bloody mamas a mercenary
group of absolute frothing psychos
brienne kills three of them in a 1v3
fight with a little help from pod and in
the next fight she kills raj the mad dog
of saltpans but then biter tackles her
and eats some of brienne's face before
she's saved by gendry so brienne is
often underestimated for being a woman
but with her great strength skill and
sheer tenacity brienne wins a lot of
fights and defeats some of the greatest
knights in westeros
number seven is garland tyrell the
gallant garland wasn't in the tv show
but in the books he's an older brother
of loris garland isn't as famous as
loris but he is bigger and stronger and
laura says that garland is a better
swordsman than him author george martin
said the same thing we see that garland
often trains by fighting three or four
men at once so that he's better prepared
for real battle
garland fights magnificently at the
battle of the blackwater he kills guyard
morrigan in single combat and a dozen
other great knights when margaery faces
a trial by combat it's garland she wants
as her champion
so we haven't seen much of garland but
he's clearly an exceptional warrior
number six is gregor clegane the
mountain that rides gregor is
monstrously huge almost eight feet tall
and weighing 400 pounds or 200 kilos all
of it muscle gregor is inhumanly strong
he often cuts men in half with a single
blow gregor wields a two-handed
greatsword in one hand so he's got a
monstrously long reach he's surprisingly
quick and doesn't seem to feel pain
no other knight in the realm inspires
such terror as the mountain the hound
says that no one could ever withstand
gregor but what are his accomplishments
in combat in book 1 the mountain attacks
loris and the hound and tries to kill
them but he fails the hound stops the
mountain and deflects his massive blows
the mountain fights in some battles in
the war he kills beric dondarrion twice
he kills raymond darry and his horse in
a single blow then in tyrion's trial by
combat gregor fights oberyn martell and
oberyn uses his speed and skill and
poison to mortally wound gregor impaling
him with a spear though gregor still
kills oberyn in the end then the mad
scientist qyburn transforms the mountain
into a mysterious undead warrior called
robert strong this silent knight may be
even more dangerous than the mountain
was but we haven't seen him in action
yet in the books
so the mountain is extremely powerful
but we've never seen him beat a really
top-tier opponent skilled warriors like
oberyn and the hound can stop him so
number five is the hound sandor clegane
the hound is a big man tall muscled like
a bull and he's quick fighting with a
terrible savagery
sandor is a twisted bitter man whose
greatest joy in life is killing he's
been killing men since he was 12 years
old knights lords women and children
everyone knows the hound is deadly with
a sword and his snarling dog helm is
widely feared even jaime says that the
hound is a dangerous powerful warrior
author george martin said the hound is
one of the greatest swordsmen in
westeros and we've seen this in action
in book one the hound stops the mountain
despite all the mountain's strength and
rage he can't kill his brother
the hound flees the battle of the
blackwater because he's afraid of fire
but in book 3 he overcomes his fear to
kill beric dondarrion killing beric is
basically a clegane family tradition at
this point
the hound kills some men at the twins in
a 3v1 fight then with the help of arya
he kills some of gregor's men even
though he's blind drunk the hound's
wounds get infected and he's left for
dead but in book four the hound seems to
have survived and found a peaceful life
as a monk maybe he'll return to fight
his zombie brother in the next book
so the hound has a proven record as a
powerful skilled warrior
but the fourth best warrior in westeros
is a young robert baratheon in book one
robert is fat drunk and past his prime
but 20 years ago when he took the throne
robert was the fiercest warrior in the
realm he was six and a half feet tall
towering over his enemies in his armor
and antlered helmet he had a giant
strength wielding a huge iron warhammer
that ned stark could barely lift in his
rebellion against the targaryens robert
won many battles fighting fearlessly on
the front lines at gulltown he was the
first up the walls and killed lord
grafton by his own hand at summerhall
robert won three battles in one day and
killed lord phil in single combat he
lost a battle at ashford but then he won
the battle of the bells and killed six
men including the famous knight miles
mooton
finally robert won the battle of the
trident personally killing prince
rhaegar targaryen who was renowned as a
skilled warrior and so robert won the
war and became king of westeros making
him one of the most successful warriors
ever he won all these battles personally
killing many knights and lords and no
one ever managed to kill him
except eventually for a pig and his wife
and his crippling alcoholism but in his
prime robert was one of the greatest
warriors in westeros
number three is jaime lannister the
kingslayer before he lost his hand
barristan selmy thinks of jaime as one
of the best natural swordsmen he's seen
jaime says that in his prime he was
bigger stronger and quicker than lloris
he's confident that with his skill and
speed he could beat the mountain and the
hound author george martin often names
jaime as one of if not the best fighters
in westeros he said jaime would beat
aragorn in a fight he said jaime would
beat hermione in a fight he said jaime
could beat a cult of cthulhu
jaime won a tournament melee when he was
just 13 years old at 15 he fought the
kingswood brotherhood and held his own
against the notorious smiling night
jaime was knighted by arthur dayne and
became the youngest kingsguard ever in
the main series he kicks ass in several
battles covering himself in glory he
cuts through edmure's army like an axe
through ripe cheese at the whispering
wood he fights through the northern army
and almost kills robb stark he only
stops because his sword gets stuck in a
north man's skull
even after being imprisoned and weakened
for months he still almost beats brienne
brienne thinks that at his full strength
no knight in the seven kingdoms could
have stood against jaime
once jaime loses his hand he's no longer
a great fighter but his battles his
reputation and the words of the author
show that jaime is one of the best
warriors in westeros
number two is a young barristan selmy
barristan the bold is widely recognized
as the greatest knight alive he is a
living legend when he was young
barristan was the finest sword in the
seven kingdoms and he has a long list of
accomplishments in combat barristan rode
in his first tournament at 10 years old
at 16 he performed great feats of
prowess in a tournament and defeated
duncan the tall lord commander of the
kingsguard at 23 he joined the
kingsguard himself and won many more
victories in tournaments and melees he
defeated all challengers at the silver
bridge
barristan defeated simon toyne of the
kingswood brotherhood barristan ended
the war of the nine penny kings by
killing maelys the monstrous in single
combat and barristan ended the defiance
of duskendale king aerys targaryen got
kidnapped and held hostage by house
darkland so in an act of crazy courage
barristan single-handedly rescued the
king he climbed the walls of duskendale
with his bare hands killed a bunch of
gods and knights and escaped with aerys
despite taking an arrow to the chest
in the battle of the trident barristan
fought for the targaryens but he was so
badass that when robert took over he
decided to keep barristan on the
kingsguard in the time of the main
series barristan is in his 60s and he's
still an exceptional fighter still
winning tournaments still better than
the other kingsguard after he joins
daenerys he kills the titans bastard
with a stick he kills a deadly dothraki
warrior and he leads a cavalry charge in
the siege of moraine barristan has been
winning fights for six decades and is
universally recognised as the greatest
knight alive but there is one warrior
who is better
first some honorable mentions oberyn
martel the red viper has a great
reputation as a warrior and he's very
skilled but the one time we see him
fight he dies
brawn is a deadly warrior who tyrion
compares to jaime thoros of mir beats
the hound in melees three times probably
because thoros uses flaming swords carl
drogo has never lost a fight but we
never see him fight an armored knight
great jon umber is so big and tough that
when his fingers get eaten he laughs
mance raider became king of the
wildlings by killing a bunch of his
rivals andrick the unsmiling is said to
be the greatest fighter in the iron
islands but we don't know anything about
him darkstar is said to be the most
dangerous man in dawn he's also the
edgiest emo in dawn and strong belvos is
such a confident gladiator that he lets
his opponents cut him before he kills
them belvos survives poison eats liver
and onions and takes a literal [ __ ] on
his opponents
the kitten sir pounce has the impressive
combat feat of scaring off bellerion a
notably fearsome tomcat however sir
pounce fails to prevent lady whiskers
from stealing his mouse so sir pouncer's
combat record is mixed at best
so the number one best warrior in
westeros is arthur dayne the sword of
the morning
arthur died 20 years ago but he's
remembered as the deadliest of aerys's
kingsguard deadlier than barristan and
deadlier than jaime jaime says that
arthur could have killed five kingsguard
with his left hand while taking a piss
with his right ned stark said that
arthur was the finest knight he ever saw
arthur wielded the legendary ancient
sword dawn said to be forged from the
heart of a meteor george martin said
that with dorne arthur would beat
barristan in a fight arthur killed the
smiling knight who was like the mountain
of his time
arthur apparently died fighting ned
stark and howland reed in the show it's
revealed that howland stabbed arthur in
the back but in the books this whole
situation is still a mystery there's so
much we don't know about arthur his only
fights mentioned in the books are with
ned stark and the smiling knight so we
only know he's the best warrior ever
because the characters and the authors
say so many characters think of arthur
with nostalgia rose tinted glasses for a
bygone time so was arthur really that
great or is he just the idealized symbol
of a noble knight how can we ever know
if he would have beaten the hound or
brienne in a fight george martin has
said that the whole idea of ranking the
best fighters is kind of dumb there is
no objective answer who would win in a
fight depends on the situation on the
day on random chance it depends on the
relationships and the emotions of the
people involved a song of ice and fire
isn't about the sword fights it's about
the story and the characters and themes
but we won't let that stop us comment
below your top 10 best fighters or top
20 how would you rank oberyn and the
great john and bellewas we have almost
finished two big videos about dune that
will come out soon and the game of
thrones prequel tv show house of the
dragon will start in august we'll make
videos about that too so subscribe to
alt shift x turn on the bell follow the
podcast and thank you to the supporters
on patreon including trish ledoux
baumbart dewees joseph barkermeyer white
fifty ever pat rion stephen hancock 81
carol moraz leia blaze delton imperial
and hierarchical lobster cheers